what's happening there reject nation i'm james
this is my co-host mason hawkins how are you
doing red hot comic book movie news shooting up
your butthole i don't i think we can say maybe
we'll see hey guys we got some bad news but maybe
okay news maybe whatever news for a lot of people
it's really bad news and i wanted to talk about it
today it's involving uh director john watts this
story broke yesterday hour today of the time
of filming it enter the twilight so guys time
travel videos in advance yeah so i wanted to talk
about uh how spider-man director john watts has
quit the fantastic four movie something else came
out online that i wanted to touch on about john
krasinski replacing john watts in the director's
seat that's gonna be fun john watts did put out a
statement saying making three spider-man films was
an incredible and life-changing experience for me
i'm eternally grateful to have been part i'm
worried i got a booger in my nose do i don't
certain turn to face me i'm eternally grateful to
have been a part of the marvel cinematic universe
for seven years um hopefully we'll work together
again it's interesting to put it that way i'm
hopeful we'll work together again so nothing
else in the pipeline nothing about another
spider-man four and i can't wait to see the
amazing oh my god spider-man easter egg amazing
vision oh my god one division we're fantastic for
brought to life multiverse of quotes right here
and then uh kevin feige said something else kevin
feige collaborating with john on the spider-man
films has been a true pleasure we were looking
forward to continuing our work with him to bring
the fantastic four into the mcu but understand and
are supportive of his reasons for stepping away we
are optimistic that we will have the opportunity
to work together again at some point down the road
see sometimes when you put this stuff in writing
i get so curious to know what is the tone of this
what is the body language collaboration with john
the spider-man films yeah true pleasure well you
know like they're both saying you know hopefully
down the road will work together again so it
doesn't sound like they've ended on bad blood in
fact deadline this is not not a quote here but
deadline did say in their article nothing sinister
oh my god senator six nothing sinister here watts
just needs a break from the superhero realm after
completing the spidey trilogy with tom holland and
zendaya i totally get that like the russo brothers
they had to stop after end game john watts you
know he me the first thing i think he did before
he got this movie was like the movie cop just like
a small thriller he does have another movie in
the works i believed with apple studios that's
supposed to start george clooney and brad pitt
and it's going to be even bigger than spider-man
yeah the biggest crossover every celebrity
is going to be in it when you commit like 10
years of your life to filming one specific story
i completely understand when someone goes you know
what maybe i don't want to take on the pressure
revitalizing fantastic four a franchise that just
does not seem to do well when translating from
comic book to film i believe marvel studios can do
it it's just there is more pressure on it to start
that process all over again to go from i just
redid spider-man it went great it's one of the
biggest movies ever maybe i should take a break
for a while and leave on a bit of a high note to
start with fantastic four i could just imagine
what the pressure would feel like to go the last
couple franchises didn't do so well this one has
to work this one has to be good finally in the
mcu yeah this needs to be perfect at all cause
yeah and knowing the filming process of how no
way home went down too every film usually has
constant rewrites but they go in with a whole
different variable of rewrites which is like we
don't know the ending yeah but we have a lot of
moving parts and pieces we have to remove plot
lines we got to put stuff back in we got actors
we don't have access to all sorts of craziness
from the past yeah so to go through the upheaval
battle of putting one of those together again from
that sounds it does sound daunting and i get
why you want to re-center yourself and just go
back to yeah this is why i love filmmaking and i
think the two if you look at the progress of the
mcu spider-man films it took until the third one i
think a lot of people would agree for john watts's
voice as a director to really start to feel like
it's informing how the movie is shaped and is
moving and you know the committee is involved
with all of them but the third one easily felt
like the one most authored by him and i feel like
the fantastic four movie probably puts a director
in a position where they have to again because of
all that baggage from the past because of people's
collective memory of all that it doesn't seem like
you would have as much room to be free and to you
know really indulge your cinematic instincts and
expertise whereas you know two i think it's got to
be enriching i think for any filmmaker who's just
spent a decade doing a character as big as this
also having to answer for the past of that
character and years and years worth of legacy i
think you need to leave and go collect some other
inspirations and stretch your legs out a little
differently and then yeah come back and i mean
he he did no way home if he wants to come back
they'll make it happen yeah yeah yeah yeah the
ability to slap from the director of spiderman
no way home on any trailer means money of course
of course of course yeah that's a great point
now let's talk about who could possibly replace
him a lot of people felt from the beginning that
otto had been paid in reid the one who helmed the
ant-man films and i do think peyton reed would be
a fantastic choice all puns intended however there
was a tweet by the greatest leaker of them all ha
ha look at toby this is toby mcguire nick that's
right that's his main claim to fame john gambia he
put this out here and uh twitter's been running
away with it he says i'll say it i'll say it
finger wave john krasinski has agreed to direct
fantastic four and that's the real reason why we
didn't say why real reason john watts stepped down
[ __ ] promised him another juicy mcu film later
if he agreed to go along with the bs i just need a
break excuse i mean i believe that i need a rival
now before proceeding forward a little bit
later he did say i thought it was clear but
since a couple people are asking this is
not a report this is my guess fair enough
i however the way you phrase that inside
information and being like that's the real
reason why because it's one thing if like i
say that [ __ ] but it's another thing when
with someone who does have more industry insider
information did do something with some photos
for a previous film and then had to go here's
why i think it's fake and probably favorite
yeah yeah yeah he didn't try taking this tweet
down oh my god can't be actually deleted the tweet
if you definitely did the tweet does that mean
that was actually something real is he's trying
to cover his tracks what is going on here what
is going on here odds are probably doesn't know
even though when i go online i'm like a lot of
people are going i bet john campio actually knows
something and he's now he's trying to like cover
it you know well this is the great thing about
all these leaks and the andrew garfield stuff
and yada yada yada is now i feel like up until
anything comes out it could be anyone's game you
know someone could be guessing properly someone
could actually know somebody could just be
throwing out a theory i mean i think it's
funny that he led with i'll say it because that
just implies that it's either gonna be a hot take
or a piece of info he was sitting on yeah instead
of like i'm accustomed to hearing john put his
opinion out there and speculating so i don't
feel like i'll say it really is necessary if
that's what you're doing and you don't want people
to be confused by that yeah but yeah i mean it's a
decent theory and hey if john watts really didn't
want to leave that seems like the absolute most
gracious way to be like yeah sure john take
it over because no one's gonna be happy that
i stayed if they hear you once yeah maybe i mean
i think john watts would have been fantastic but
krasinski who's done like his most notable
directing gigs is like his most popular ones
are horror films i think maybe the theory comes
into mind of john krasinski would star in it as
mr fantastic only if he could direct it you know
which i would be cool with i'd be excited i'll
be honest you know a lot of people want john
krasinski to direct this and there's nothing
i've seen in a quiet place that makes me go you'd
be great for example that's fantastic for granted
i don't know the other films he's done so for me
i only have to go off of a quiet place yeah i'm
sure he'd do a just a really fine job either way
regardless i want john krasinski as mr fantastic
make it happen make it happen mark cowards don't
be a [ __ ] the way you've done john watts dirty
yeah yeah well you shipped him in the back that's
right you threw him overboard threw him under that
zinske yeah you jerks you're a bunch of jerks
marvel signed him on in twenty twenty years
why would a director wanna break especially after
working on this for over a year and being involved
in the biggest whirlwind of media frenzy over a
movie in a long time a bunch of bs yeah there's
no way he would want to break money talks maybe
guys who would you want to take over for directing
fantastic four mel gibson edgar wright no i'm
pretty sure mel gibson is definitely mel gibson
get him to play mr francis that'd be great
or doctor doom or doctor both actually be a
good doctor dude he would be a good doctor doom
that's the kind of doctor all right see you guys
you